vielleicht erinnert ihr euch noch daran
wie ich letztes Jahr meinen eigenen Mini
Tesla gebaut habe der dann am Ende mit
Hilfe seines Bordcomputers eine vorher
einprogrammierte Strecke komplett von
alleine abfahren konnte aber man kann es
natürlich auch selbst steuern mit dem
ferngesteuerten Auto ein bisschen durch
die Wohnung zu flitzen ist zwar nice
aber wechselnde Rennstrecken und Gegner
gegen die man antreten kann hat man da
ja normal nicht ganz anders ist das im
Videospiel Mario Kart homes worksuit in
denen das Auto der Kamera hat wodurch
man das Auto so steuern kann als würde
man selbst drin sitzen und wo zusätzlich
streckenbegrenzungen und Gegner virtuell
eingefügt werden genauso was ähnliches
will ich auch machen nur viel besser und
realistischer mit RTX damit das am Ende
am besten komplett real aussieht das
ganze ermöglichen wird man Nvidia Studio
PC von milfcom mit dem ich die komplette
Rennstrecke und gegnerische Autos 3D
modellieren werde und die verbaute
Grafikkarte die NVIDIA GeForce RTX 3090
wird uns definitiv dabei helfen die
Grenzen zwischen Realität und
Virtualität verschwimmen zu lassen
vielen Dank also an mitkommen und Nvidia
für die Unterstützung bei diesem Projekt
und damit weiter mit dem Video
[Musik]
Informationen aus der digitalen Welt
über die Realität drüber zu legen und
somit eine Art metaverse zu erschaffen
nennt sich Augmented Reality oder kurz
are in der Regel wird es dabei dass
Filmmaterial z.B eine Handykamera oder
VR Brille in Echtzeit 3D getrackt
wodurch dann 3D Objekte und Texte so
überlagert werden können dass es
aussieht als wären sie wirklich dort und
wenn diese Objekte dann noch super
realistisch aussehen dann kann man
teilweise gar nicht unterscheiden was
echt ist und was nicht bevor ich jetzt
aber anfangen
und Programmier am PC samt gegnerische
Autos und allem drum und dran muss ich
erstmal rausfinden ob ich das überhaupt
machen kann also Realität mit virtuellen
vermischen das ganze mit einem
gespeicherten Video zu machen ist
relativ leicht und habe ich als visuelle
Effekt artist im Ruhestand natürlich
auch schon oft gemacht wie z.B bei
diesem Video für den Youtuber Julien BAM
der Computer verfolgt einzelne markante
Punkte Bild für Bild und errechnet sich
dann die dreidimensionale Bewegung der
Kamera im Verhältnis zu eben diesen
Punkten was dann so aussieht und in
diese 3D-Szene setzt man dann z.B einen
Würfel der dann über das Filmmaterial
gelegt wird zack wir haben ein Objekt
dran gecheckt oder in diesem konkreten
Fall für Julien BamS Video unsichtbare
Bikinis fragt mich nicht wieso das war
zu Idee das ganze muss bei AA natürlich
in Echtzeit gehen und da ich mich mit
dem Programm schon bisschen auskennen
werde ich das mit Unity versuchen mit
dem ich auch schon meine Jump and Run
App dinoscape programmiert und in den
App Store gebracht habe und das beste
ist Unity wird wie z.B auch Blender und
Adobe Programme von den Nvidia Studio
Treibern in meinem mistkom PC supportet
wodurch der Topf Performance vor allem
beim RTX haben werden
[Musik]
Recherche und TÜV die neue habe ich mir
jetzt so eine Art Erweiterung
installiert mit welcher Szene Kamera
erstellen kann dann kann ich da so ein
Zielbild hochladen da muss ich noch die
Größe davon einstellen 129 jetzt kann
ich auf dieses Zielbild in 3D Objekt
draufklatschen so als 3D Objekt habe ich
ja z.B mein maclip ausgewählt und wenn
ich dann Start drücke weiß ja noch gar
nichts warte drücke erstmal meine Webcam
und mein Zielbild habe ich mir jetzt
auch mein echt ausgedruckt und wenn ich
das jetzt hier quasi ins Webcam halte
dieses Zielbild kann man natürlich auch
auf dem Tisch oder auf dem Boden legen
und das funktioniert wirklich extrem gut
und das ist schon einmal echt krass also
das nicht und alles möglich ist noch
nicht perfekt dass wir noch angepasst
aber die Technik die funktioniert schon
mal und ich weiß nicht wieso der jetzt
einfach so rumhängt weil eigentlich
sollte er hier drauf sein einfach krass
allerdings soll natürlich das jetzt
nicht hier über meine Webcam
funktionieren das wäre ziemlich
langweilig sondern über die Kamera im
Auto ob ihr es glaubt oder nicht die
Kamera ist eine extreme Herausforderung
im ersten Teil in dem ich das Auto
gebaut habe ist es mir nicht gelungen
auf das Videosignal der Kamera
zuzugreifen die ich an den Bordcomputer
gesteckt habe das konnte ich allerdings
super leicht beheben mit etwas Hilfe vom
Youtuber Morpheus Tutorial ist der
Videos über Informatik macht und mir
schon bei meinem hacken lernen Video
geholfen hat diese winzige Kamera
funktioniert also jetzt und darüber
könnte das Auto jetzt auch lernen selbst
zu fahren und sonstige künstliche
intelligenzgeschichten allerdings will
ich ja dass das möglichst realistisch
aussieht und dafür brauche ich eine
dickere Kamera und da die Kameras die
ich für meine Videos benutze viel zu
schwer sind und bei dem Crash auch
kaputt gehen könnten verbaue ich eine
Action Cam genau das hier ist die Kamera
die habe ich jetzt über ein Kabel
verbunden mit meinem PC wodurch jetzt
quasi hier im PC genau das Video Signal
von der Kamera hier sehe und einmal
überall rum filmen kann und auf der Höhe
wird die Kamera dann ungefähr im Auto
sein allerdings bevor ich das ins Auto
verbauen muss ich natürlich eine Lösung
finden wie ich das ganze auch kabellos
gemanagt kriegt und quasi das
Filmmaterial von dem Teil auf dem
Bordcomputer schickt und dann von
Bordcomputer aus zu meinem PC ich lege
einfach mal los keine Ahnung ob ich das
hinkriegt ich nehme jetzt quasi einmal
die komplette Abdeckung ab die ganzen
Scheiben raus alles Mögliche für das
jetzt quasi diesen Bordcomputer hier
einzeln und frei rumliegen hat und das
allererstes brauche ich mein Monitor für
den PC und Monitor habe ich genug
rumliegen deswegen nehme
mein normaler PC sondern dieser kleine
hier so jetzt kann ich ja meine Maus und
Tastatur auch anstecken und jetzt habe
ich hier
quasi ein ganz normalen Computer in
diesem Auto hier drin ist geil oder
so und dass ich jetzt quasi das Bild von
der GoPro an diesem PC geschickt so und
jetzt so das funktioniert muss ich die
Kamera nur noch irgendwo befestigen und
irgendwie das wieder
zusammen montieren so dass es nicht
aussieht wie ein Haufen wie ein Haufen
eben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so und wenn ich jetzt mit dem Auto vor
bist in diesem Startseite fahre
dann erkennt er das nicht ja so klappt
das nicht aber ist auch kein Problem
denn ich will ja auch gar nicht dass am
Ende die Rennstrecke nur da ist wo
dieser kleine Zettel ist sondern im
ganzen Raum und dafür muss der ganze
Raum das Zielbild sein und das kenne ich
jetzt in 3D 1
über so eine Schicht drüber über alles
[Musik]
später wird natürlich das Auto hier am
Boden rumfahren gut jetzt sagte mir er
ist jetzt fertig jetzt kann ich
irgendwie dann mal stark drücken und
jetzt dass das 5 Minuten dauert dabei
entstand die auf meinem Handy liegt und
das muss jetzt mit irgendeinem
speziellen App noch mal auf meinen PC
ziehen und jetzt habe ich eben so eine
spezielle Datei hier am PC die kann ich
dann einfach quasi da reinziehen in das
Programm mit dem ich dieses Spiel quasi
entwickelt so jetzt mache ich so ein
area Tage dran
Office 2 oha jetzt habe ich hier ey das
ist ja krass und jetzt habe ich hier
quasi das Büro in 3D das sieht jetzt
nicht unbedingt schön aus aber jetzt
haben wir hier nämlich kein Zielbild
mehr sondern ganzen Zielraum und immer
wenn jetzt die Kamera irgendwas in
diesem Raum sieht platziert ihr dann
quasi Objekte rein und zwar dahin wo wir
sie hinsetzen so dann soll ich mir jetzt
von Dinosaurier so hier steht jetzt also
der T-Rex mitten in meinem Raum und
idealerweise wenn alles funktioniert ist
es so dass das Auto das aussieht wir
testen das warum geht das nicht das hier
ist eines der Projekte bei denen ich
mehr über mich lerne als über das was
ich eigentlich machen sollte und das
liegt einmal daran dass ich an dem Punkt
an dem ich jetzt angekommen bin kaum
noch Informationen dazu finde über das
was ich erreichen will aber auch daran
dass der Upload von diesem Video
mittlerweile schon um ganze drei Wochen
verschoben wurde weil naja nichts auf
Anhieb klappt wie ich es mir erhoffe
gleichzeitig Bäumen sich links und
rechts neue spannende Projektideen auf
weswegen ich wirklich sehr viel
Disziplin aufbringen muss am Ball zu
bleiben aber die Disziplin die die
braucht man natürlich immer wenn man
etwas Tolles schaffen will
es geht einfach da ist jetzt einmal
T-Rex okay es ruckelt halt noch hart der
Track dass ich noch nicht so richtig
muss ich noch fixen
[Musik]
aber hey es ist geil das einmal jetzt
ein Teil ist mitten im Raum
ich habe jetzt ohne Witz allein dafür
dass das funktioniert drei Tage
gebraucht 3 das sieht jetzt aber noch
ein bisschen unrealistisch aus und vor
allem noch überhaupt nicht wie ein
gegnerisches Fahrzeug also habe ich mir
ein 3D Modell von der Muscle Car
organisiert dass ich jetzt gerade hier
noch in Blender bearbeite blender ist
übrigens genau wie Unity eins der vielen
Programme für kreative die von den
Nvidia Studio Treiber unterstützt werden
und damit perfekt mit der RTX 3090 in
meinem Nvidia Studio PC zusammenarbeiten
der 16 Kern Risen 9 5 950x und die 64GB
Arbeitsspeicher hauen natürlich auch
rein den Link zum Mitkommen findet
übrigens auch in der Videobeschreibung
wenn ihr euch auch für so ein PC
interessiert dass das Ganze in Blender
also einer speziell für 3D modeling und
Rendering gemacht das Software so ultra
geil und realistisch aussehen kann ist
ja irgendwo klar in Computerspielen die
mit Unity gemacht werden allerdings
sehen die Objekte normal nicht ganz so
krass aus wie ihr es hier sehen könnt
damit aber auch das jetzt ultra aussieht
kann ich nun RTX also Raytracing
aktivieren wie ihr das vielleicht vom
Computer spielen wie Cyberpunk oder
Minecraft kennt
damit werden Licht Schatten und
Spiegelungen extrem realistisch und vor
allem auch in Echtzeit berechnet leider
gibt's hier nicht einfach einen an
Ausschalter sowie einen Computerspiel
sondern ich habe viel kreative Freiheit
und muss daher einige Dinge dafür
einstellen wie z.B Global Illumination
Ambient oblusion und Generator Reflexion
mega geil sieht das aus wir sind aber
noch lange nicht am Ende das sind
insgesamt so viele Einzelteile die hier
zusammenarbeiten müssen und gleichzeitig
funktionieren müssen das Auto muss
fahren und ferngesteuert werden können
die Kamera muss kabellos und fast
komplett ohne Verzögerung ein gutes
Video senden Unity muss das Video
verarbeiten können die 3D Modelle müssen
realistisch beleuchtet und gerendert
werden und diese ganze Komposition will
ich dann an meine VR Brille sehen damit
so aussehen als würde ich das Fahrzeug
wirklich selber steuern damit man das
Gefühl hat dass man wirklich selber am
Steuer des Autos sitzt das sind alles so
unfassbar viele Sachen die alle nicht
schief gehen dürfen und wie es aussieht
bin ich an einer Art Wegsperre
angekommen an der ist nicht mehr
weitergeht ich kann zwar in Echtzeit
dieses Augmented Reality Gedöns machen
mit diesem Zielbild als trackingmarker
und das sieht auch echt extrem gut aus
aber die Funktion Objekte ohne Zielbild
direkt in einen gescannten Raum zu
tracken wie hier mit den Dino das klappt
nur wie vorhin über Filmmaterial dass
ich im Vorfeld aufgenommen habe und zwar
mit einem Handy und dort am Handy also
wenn ich jetzt dieses kleine Programm
dass ich entwickelt habe als App
speichern würde dann würde am Handy das
ganze sogar live funktionieren
allerdings haben wir da leider niemals
genug Rechenpower um das zu realistisch
aussehen zu lassen und natürlich würde
dann auch das mit der Virtual Reality
Brille nicht funktionieren und das
wirklich frustrierende ist das ist dafür
aber eigentlich keinen guten Grund gibt
außer das scheinbar jeder Augmented
Reality für Handys programmieren will
aber keiner für PC deswegen haben die
ganzen Entwickler für diese
verschiedenen Augmented Reality Plugins
und Erweiterungen halt einfach noch
nicht mal dran gedacht die sind einfach
nicht mal auf die Idee gekommen das für
ein PC zu aktivieren der ja normal im
Gegensatz zu dem Handy auch keine
eingebaute Kamera hat aber bei dem das
ganze natürlich ansonsten problemlos
klappen würde und von der Rechenpower
her natürlich sogar noch viel besser ja
und ohne diese speziellen Erweiterung
die sich jetzt also quer stellt habe ich
ja ich weiß wirklich nicht wie ich als
Laie als absoluter Noob da jetzt noch
weitermachen kann
[Musik]
wisst ja ich bin seit über vier Wochen
dran habe jede Methode getestet dutzende
Bugs ausgebügelt und ich glaube ich bin
vielleicht der erste der bei sich zu
Hause ein über dem PC ferngesteuertes
aber reales selbst gebautes Auto per VR
Brille in Ego Perspektive steuern will
durch eine fiktive aber täuschen echt
wirkende Rennstrecke die von der besten
Grafikkarte auf dem Markt zum Leben
erweckt wird und ja die Beschreibung
muss ich gerade ablesen weil selbst für
mich klingt das nach ungefähr fünf
Wochen immer noch mega verrückt aber es
besteht ja generell jede Aufgabe egal
wie kompliziert aus mehreren einzelnen
Puzzleteilen und alle einzelnen
Puzzleteile von denen ich vorhin
gesprochen habe die funktioniert
mittlerweile ich habe ihn selbst
gebautes und ferngesteuertes Auto an
meinem Nvidia Studio PC von mitkommt
Design und dann gebaut und das
funktioniert ich habe eine stabile
Kamera und ich habe es nach tagelang als
fünfte leider endlich geschafft dass sie
ein Full HD wieder meinen PC schickt
ohne Verzögerung ich habe gelernt wie
man Augmented Reality Apps programmiert
fürs Handy und natürlich zum Teil auch
für den PC und das fiktive in die
Realität bringen ich weiß jetzt wie man
mit ATX fiktive Dinge fotorealistisch
aussehen lassen kann in Echtzeit und ein
simples Rennspiel kann ich auch
programmieren aber irgendwo in dieser
Puzzle Kette zwei Puzzleteile und die
kriege ich einfach nicht zusammen egal
wie ich sie drehen und wenn ich lasse
mir etwas anderes einfallen euch meine
verrückte Vision zu zeigen ich bin
versteht das meine dumme Idee überhaupt
war
[Musik]
so sieht also aus Tesla durchs
matterbörse fahren und die Idee war ihm
jetzt dass ich nicht reality Brille auf
habe und dann in Echtzeit damit gegen
Gegner antreten und ich das Gefühl habe
wirklich auf der Straße in meinem Zimmer
zu sein irgendwann werde ich
wahrscheinlich genug Wissen haben um
diese Vision komplett umzusetzen aber
mir Sicherheit wird auch wieder eine
Nvidia Grafikkarte sein die mir dabei
hilft sowie die die in meinem Nvidia
Studio PC verbaut ist die dir so oder
perfekt auf euch angepasst bei mir kommt
kaufen könnt wie ihr gesehen habt kann
man damit nicht nur Spiele entwickeln
sondern auch visuelle facts erstellen
und 3D Modelle modellieren und jeder
kann bei mitkommen sein PC ganz
individuell auf seine Bedürfnisse
anpassen und ihre Content dann fertig
zusammengebaut geliefert der Link dazu
ist in der Videobeschreibung und damit
verabschiede ich mich mach's gut Ciao
ich glaube ich mache jetzt erstmal
Urlaub Alter das nenne ich mal ein
Projekt